food dining experience the x-spot is
celebrating its two-year anniversary
along with their extensive list of wines
and whiskies this weekend's menu will
feature a sake and tasting menu by a
special michelin star chef take a look
when you come to
the x-pot and you think of hotpot you
think of a friendly family gathering
eight of your closest friends three and
a half hours of just sitting in front of
the tv with cheap cuts of meat we've
gone and elevated that and we've
introduced the fine dining experience to
the ajo tradition of hot pot as you can
see around me we've got wagyu beef
galore we've got caviar and we've got
amazing seafood here we've got the
freshest cuts of beef things that you
would never see anywhere else in any
other restaurant so what's so special
about this weekend we are actually
celebrating our second year anniversary
here at the x-pot
part of our specials that we're offering
is this amazing caviar upgrade right
here as you can see as well as an
amazing dish that's traditionally served
only to uh ancient chinese emperors
right here the cucumber dish so the
weekend celebration is about the
collaboration with me as a chef and
the expo las vegas
and so our one of the signatures that i
brought here is the
caviar that you see here it's
inspired by a paint palette and it comes
with all different
accoutrements
as well as some
chinese bread with some
seaweed flakes so the restaurant opening
in la is called niku x inspired by a
japanese barbecue
so we'll be having things grilled on
charcoal
and
both wagyu seafood vegetables all using
the local
californian
vegetables and produce tip i would give
to people that haven't tried hotpot
before is it's all about sharing the
different combinations uh so we have uh
one of the popular ones is a lobster
broth that goes well with actually meat
as well so the seafood and meat
combinations is something that people
might not be used to but actually a
really
unique and tasty combination